let's talk about the latest news with
lucasfilm you guys maybe have heard
because it's been
the no it was the number one trending
story last night after we did the show
we have this from variety lucasfilm and
united talent drop mandalorian star gina
carano
following offensive social media posts
i'm sorry i don't think the posts well
look i guess offensive is in the eye of
the
beholder i suppose but she basically
made a post
it looked like she was quoting someone
else who said that in world war ii
germany
they pitted neighbor against neighbor
and that's
what gave the you know the political
party there i would just say the nazis
the ability to then round people up
they got the people of the country all
angry they were demagoguing
the crazy thing about what she posted is
it's exactly what the left has been
complaining about with donald trump they
said donald trump is a demagogue
who is villainizing people and tearing
us apart so then gina chronos basically
like yeah you know what that's what they
did in world war ii germany we shouldn't
do this and they're like oh you bigot
ban her well the big news the big update
is that
well disney's kind of getting slammed
because pedro pascal
did something very similar and he's the
star of the show so he's able to post
these comparisons claiming the us
is like nazi germany nobody cares this
should be
just proof to anybody that we're dealing
with with hypocrites
who don't actually care about what
they're saying it is absolute bs
and uh i canceled i cancelled my disney
plus you got you guys canceled jesse
plus i never got it i don't have it i
use my friends
i don't support the chat comments are
you supposed to i don't know
but i think what's interesting is that
she didn't even mention leftists or
democrats or the left in her post unless
i'm mistaken
no no there's okay so it's kind of like
if the shoe fits like if if someone's
talking about nazis and you get mad you
might be a nazi
right and and like you said the entirety
of the left has been making nazi
comparisons for the past
four or five years over trump and over
right wingers in general why did they
fire gina carano
like i've been thinking about this all
day cause i recorded a segment earlier
in the morning
it can't be for the stated reason maybe
they just didn't want her yeah
they wanted to find a reason to fire her
and they were like ooh here's our that's
our chance well she's been an undercover
hollywood conservative for a minute i
remember back and i think it was august
or september they were tried to get her
back then too
yeah because she made some kind of post
about uh pronouns
yeah she made a boot beep post
and uh which i thought was funny is that
a meme or something or is this
um it was she was making fun of like
r2d2 yeah
i'm saying that was the pronoun
it was funny she also posted about
individuals like epstein
and as you know a lot of people in
hollywood and government
are usually connected to individuals
like that and you know
it's just absolutely scary and dangerous
what's happening because it's so
orwellian it's so backwards we have
unaccountable billionaire corporate
executives deciding
which speech is okay and which which
speech they should censor because it's
dangerous when in reality them doing
that is dangerous
and it's absolutely ridiculous but
that's why i'm saying i don't think
i i feel like there's something else
going on here of course yeah because
what do you mean well the the boop bop
beep thing was
more offensive you know it was like it
was considered offensive to
uh pronouns or whatever not that not
that i think it was offensive like none
of it's offensive everyone is so
there must be something else too but i
don't get it maybe she made the wrong
people mad
yeah everyone's so defiant that's what
i'm thinking about you can't fake
offense and
there's no way i mean we saw a little of
the kind of like
outrage by the blue check marks
yesterday before the major decision was
made because we were talking about
actually talking
about this story right before we went on
and
i didn't think they'd fire her i didn't
think it would go this far and then
after the show i'm like holy cow they
they fired her from the
show and then a lot of actors are pissed
off a lot of people on the show are
pissed off and they should be i mean
this is leading towards this kind of
situation that's going to cause brain
drain in one way or another
whether it's people who want to come
here who are going to be afraid because
people are just getting canceled
because of their opinions that are milk
toast that are not even that wild that
are not even
that partisan she was talking about a
historical reference
where people were wild up so much
that they started to hate their neighbor
you know something of course that that
many people prove
by the actions today is a legitimate
threat and they proved it they proved it
exactly what's happening yeah you know
this reminded me of
when uh luke and i were in hamburg
germany for the g20
there was a moment where luke was just
walking down the street with some
just like a random local journalist and
someone pointed and yelled nazi
schweinhund
at luke and then random people who were
just sitting nearby
jumped up and ran and started punching
him but you could tell the story better
than i can well i mean
i even have history my family fighting
the nazis fighting the communists as a
polish born
proud person i'm like why am i in
germany getting called the nazi getting
attacked and jumped and beaten by
somebody
i was like are you freaking kidding me
think about this what was particularly
striking about what happened to you was
that there were people just sitting on
the ground like on the curb
and as soon as they heard the word they
jumped up having no idea who you are or
what you were doing
and started beating you and it was
brutal because like it wasn't just like
one group of people it was organized in
a way where i was able to push away get
away
and then down the block someone would
hit me and then down the block someone
else would hit me
and i'm like i i can't get i have to
keep running
because they were everywhere and they
were there was literal
squads of individuals with my photos and
a whole team of them
running around not just my photos there
was other journalist independent
journalists
mainstream media journalists that
weren't even connected to us they just
had photos taken
next to us they were just our friends
that were just there that had nothing to
do and with anything political
they got the crap beat out of them
because they had antifa hit squads
literally
looking at photos running through all
the crowds that's not the issue right
the issue is that there were people who
didn't have those photos
who were just like there's there was
like a guy and he's like sitting on the
ground eating chips and then as soon as
he hears someone yell nazi
he runs up and it's hitting luke having
no idea why he's doing it
what i see with what gina carano posted
and what and then what happens now still
with the same it's the same thing
i don't care if they're fascists or
anti-fascists they seem to love to just
randomly beat people they don't know
granted one was substantially worse
we're trying to stop the authoritarians
from moving in this direction why
because disney fires gina carano
while thanking the paramilitary group in
in
in xinjiang that is running weaker
concentration camps right so forgive me
if you're like
how dare you compare antifa to the
fascists well the antifa people
apparently are cheering on disney
who is thanking the paramilitary group
running a concentration camp
of of an uh religious minority so it
kind of feels like we're getting
dangerously close some real world
parallels
and she proved it today with her post
and and lucasfilm released the statement
and they said her
twitter posts were quote adhorent and
unacceptable
i mean are you kidding me and those are
the statements that of course twitter of
course ran with so whenever you clicked
on the story
it said gina was fired for adhorent
social media posts and of course they
don't they don't mention they don't list
what the post was and when you really
look at it jeffrey epstein this
beep bop thing this this you know nazi
comparison not even not even comparison
but just saying hey this happened during
history we shouldn't let it happen now
well
hold on hold on wasn't walt disney like
a raging anti-semite he was yes
yes well there you go he's offended
that disney's offended because she's
calling them out if anyone should be
canceled it's disney for their
participation with the with the uighur
muslim
police force the they're tied with walt
disney involved people
and you know the their their cartoons
also have a long history that that's
very controversial
there's a lot of things we can bring up
i mean if we're going to do anything not
just cancel your membership cancel
disney all in general if you want to
play by these rules cancel all of these
people yeah yeah i would tell my friend
to cancel his account that i'm using
but you know what i wish that there were
more i wish people weren't such cowards
because half of hollywood is
conservative okay
i would say half generous okay and
no one is speaking up on her behalf that
is a conservative in hollywood
no one and it's like they're just
sitting there hoping that it doesn't
eventually hit them and it's going to
whether it's in february the summer fall
at some point they're gonna get you two
because in my opinion celebrities who
don't speak about politics are always
conservatives and we talked about that
earlier it's like right
if you're not talking about it you're
probably at least right leaning and
that's all it takes because
like we said she wasn't even saying
anything super partisan i was in
i was in la a couple years ago and there
was some
like b-list celebrity guy and he was
talking to people and someone who was
you know we were out in the street one
of the guys who was there was a trump
supporter
and so he was talking to the celebrity
and then when everyone started leaving
he's like this dude voted for trump and
he goes
come on come on come on man don't tell
anybody and then he looked at me he's
like dude for sure yeah but i can't no
one can know
and it's like i get it but like i also
hate it yeah that everyone is so
cowardly because at the end of the day
because no one's speaking up it does
make the few people who speak up they
take
all of the heat and i've always talked
about that so it's
it's very frustrating i've always hung
out with some like celebrities whenever
i go to la and all of them treat me like
their secret girlfriend they're like
just don't tell anyone you know i'm like
dude you don't even got to tell me that
he's like i'm like i'm not you know fan
boring or going to take a picture with
you just relax and calm down
like i love your stuff let's talk about
this let's talk about this i want to
know about this
and then they're dying to talk about
they're dying to talk about it they love
that they have a lot of passion and i i
i'm not gonna you know tell you exactly
who it is but there's a bunch of them
and there's a big community of people
that that have to
literally be quiet about their own
personal beliefs about
something that they truly deep down
believe is true that they can't even
openly
talk about because they're scared of
getting the hammer across their head
those ideas will die with them yes
that's the point
if you don't say them they go away it's
like
it's like the mask right you wear the
mask so you can't spit the the
coronavirus at people yeah so they're
putting a mask over your ears
so that you can't well actually no it's
over it's literally a digital mask and a
physical mask
this is what's really crazy about what's
going on right i think i think the
reason they got rid of gina is not
because of this one post it's because
she's a rebel
because she defies the orthodoxy it's a
series of posts and they're like we
cannot have someone
going against us because they don't want
this individual gaining power they don't
want celebrities to go up and
foment some kind of revolt against the
establishment but i tell you what's
worrying
i mentioned this before you can't go to
a bar
the the bars are all under restrictions
so people aren't meeting each other
they're not sharing ideas not
talking so they go online but those
ideas online that are bad
are filtered out because it's hate
speech or wrong think or whatever
so what they're doing is the longer they
stay locked down
the the more they are controlling
exactly what people
think and hear and say that is so true
and you know they so i live in l.a pray
for me
and they just started reopening outdoor
dining
of course it's freezing no one's eating
outdoors but along with it was a
stipulation that you couldn't turn the
tv on in restaurants
restaurant owners could not have their
tvs on and it's like
it really is about a control of
information a controlled conversation
and like you said of meeting people
exchanging ideas starting to question
why have i been on my knees begging for
money for the past year from the
government why
like maybe the mass thing doesn't make
as much sense as people think maybe this
doesn't make as much sense it's about
control of the conversation and it's so
disturbing
we're gonna get banned instagram just
said they're gonna start banning people
for hate speech and direct messages
it's not just them i mean we could list
a whole number of individuals that were
banned that were hit today
but i think the larger context of why
this is happening is this larger
insecurity police state that we've seen
be the epitome of the biden
administration we've seen them
uh representatively be surrounded by
police officers trying to look tough
and i think this is another example of
this exemplified wit just striking
someone down who wasn't really
saying anything controversial wars
wasn't saying anything crazy but this is
going to have a chilling effect not just
in hollywood
but in the larger social media political
spectrum where people are like
well i don't want my twitter account
taken down i better not even
dare to talk about history because if i
do
they're going to destroy me and i'm
going to lose my job my agency is going
to take me down
and and then this is going to
reverberate amongst people
and we have to understand it only works
because we let it work this chilling
effect
this fear this silencing efforts have
been done in many coordinated ways and
this is why for so many reasons
big tech oligarchs social media
companies like twitter facebook youtube
they never tell you exactly why they ban
you they never give you a reason
they never give you a way to even answer
yourself or even have a fair hearing or
even have a decision that you could be
held accountable for no blanket cut
no accountability no transition sentence
life sentence
forever deleted from the discourse not
being able to talk
ever because why we don't even know so
what's the reason
people don't want to experience that and
and the way i know it's real what people
are feeling that fear that you talked
about is that
even i sometimes catch myself feeling it
and i have made a living off being
outspoken on the internet for years and
even i sometimes before i say something
i'm like
should i say that which always makes me
want to say more but still it's like
imagine
the person who is working in nine to
five who is working in a corporate
environment where they can't say
anything
you know my fiance was working at a job
where over the summer
um he's not working there anymore so i
can say this now but his job was
donating like
a ton of proceeds from the shoots he was
doing he works in production in
hollywood
from money they made to bailing out
rioters
and he couldn't say anything about it
he's like so i'm working this company
generating
revenue and they're sending that to bail
out rioters who are destroying the city
i'm living in
where i'm now unsafe because they're
destroying the city i'm living in so so
that's what it is people can't say
anything hollywood is funding terrorists
basically yeah you have people who go
around threatening you
they they threaten your business they
threaten your life they destroy it
and then you have these you know these
personalities these faux
progressives who cheer that on right
then when they deploy the national guard
and mass to dc to lock the place down
these supposed anti-fascists who think
the us government is this evil empire
cheer that on right what no these are
people who are just
they're they're they're bootlickers but
that's probably being generous they're
literally the boot
they're a tool of the state to suppress
what happened to
the acab all cops are bad what happened
to that that went out the window so
quick once they well the national guard
aren't cops so they're true
yeah but an unarmed woman was shot and
killed right
and the story now apparently this this
officer from the capitol wasn't actually
hit in the head
yeah they don't know what happened they
think the some reports i saw said they
think it may have been pepper spray well
there's reports of him
answering back and talking to family
saying he was okay and then the next day
passing away and then it's still a
mystery because we don't know what
happened and if you look at
the casualty rates i mean there's a
heart attack there's someone being
trampled it's all trump supporters
even even there's reports of the of the
officer being a trump supporter
uh and still a lot of mystery why can't
we find out what's going on especially
if we're going to be using this event
for for such an example to lead us into
this new political sphere we should
understand what happened here if we're
going to use this as an example
and keep talking about it right you know
what i love i love all of a sudden the
the democrats like falling over
themselves to defend mitt romney
there's like a video of mitt romney
being ushered to safety and they're like
mitt romney was almost hurt and i'm like
worse
is it the first time you cared about a
republican right i think so
i'm old enough to remember the things
that were said about
bush mccain romney it's like they
treated him
and maybe people that are a little
younger than me i guess i'm not that old
don't remember but they treated them
just like trump
like romney was racist and sexist and
mccain was racist and sexist and so was
what
i don't know huh dog on the car oh i
remember that i don't remember that
like if you put a dog carry on his roof
or something yeah i don't remember
mitt romney is awful he is awful but
it's like he's rewriting and suddenly
everyone loves him it's like ugh
i can i can respect that they don't want
the man to get hurt i don't want to get
hurt either i might not like the guy but
i wish him nothing but safety and you
know a long life and happiness with his
family
so i get it but i just love this idea
that people screaming he was a fascist
trying to take over the country in 2012
all of a sudden they're like this poor
man oh okay we have to understand these
are limited people
and their reactions that benefit the
establishment
these are a few people these are not the
majority of people these are not a big
representation of everyone
uh you know there's not that many of
them but when they do speak their voices
are elevated through the algorithms
through
of course the the news feeds that curate
and make you see this
to spin this larger divide and conquer
cycle and i think
by and large people don't like this
because when you look at the number one
downloaded app in the world right now
can you guys guess what it is
tick tock talk nope telegram telegram
the third
the third one is signal all
communication efforts i heard negative
things about telegram i still have to do
more research about this
they've been accused of censoring posts
as well and working with governments i
still haven't been able to verify that i
need to do my own research on that
but when you look at telegram when you
look at signal they represent
communications that are away
from the control of the state away from
the moderators away from the mainstream
media
that will censor you and try to ruin you
and take away your job and take away
your existence
as a human being in our society for
having the wrong political opinion
and essentially i mean what we're seeing
here is is journalists
some blue check mark individuals being
highlighted promoted by these big tech
oligarchs
that are celebrating the destruction of
someone's career and that's sick
in its own twisted own way and the
analogy i had here
it's it's like they're smelling blood in
the water but the sharks aren't the
journalists
the big tech billionaires are the sharks
and the journalists are the bottom
feeders that are eating off the shark's
poop
family-friendly show i was going to say
something else that's the analogy of
what's happening right now
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time